(music crescendos)
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
So here's the thing.
- Tell me.
- I saw you backstage and I was like, man,
a lot of times actors are shorter
(Jay laughing)
and you're not.
Like, like you see 'em
on and you always think,
oh man, they're all tall.
And then you go to events
and you're like, oh.
Like a lot of 'em are like
average height, right?
And then it's like you're not,
you're like super tall, man.
- Super?
- I, well, I'm five three, so yes.
- I'm six three.
- Okay. See, that's
- A full foot.
- That's super tall, I'm an actual smurf
standing next to you.
(Jay laughing)
- Or I'm an ogre.
- So, yeah. No, it's cool
to be tall. It's cool.
No, you had such a big year last year
with "Top Gun: Maverick."
- Yeah.
- And you got married.
(audience cheering)
You got married.
- Yeah, it was a big year.
- That's a big year.
Where, did you plan to do
all that? That's a lot.
- No, my wedding was a COVID,
like, casualty actually.
We were originally supposed to get married
the summer of 2020.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah, we had a good time.
- It's a shame she is not attractive
(Jay and audience laughing)
and you're not attractive.
Y'all look like those
people when you buy frames
- It's not a real picture?
- No, yeah it's like you
look like actors that, well
(Jay laughing)
- but you look like you're
just like paid to be in the photo
'cause you're so beautiful.
- Well, we ended up
getting married in Italy.
We were supposed to get married in 2020.
Yeah, and
- Where in Italy?
- We got married just south
of Florence and Tuscany.
- Okay.
- The first trip my wife and I
ever took together was to Italy.
She lived there for 10 years
and worked there for a long time, so
- Oh.
- We decided we wanted
to do a destination thing
so we got like,
- That's so cool.
- 200 of our closest friends
to come party with us in Italy.
- I love, I'm literally
about to take a trip in March to Italy.
I love Italy.
(audience clapping)
- Where are you going?
- We're going around Tuscany.
- Yeah.
- It's like, I've been all around
but I've never really
- So fun.
- like, I don't know,
adventured in that area, but.
So I heard that someone famous
showed up at your wedding,
that your mom was more excited about
(Jay laughing)
than you getting married.
- Yeah. So I've known Anna Kendrick,
we were introduced through
a good friend of ours
Tommy Alter, who hosts this
podcast with JJ Reddick,
and we were out at dinner one night
and we were all talking about summer plans
and everyone was like, oh,
"I'm gonna be in Europe,
I'm gonna be in Europe,"
and we're like, okay, cool.
Like, if we see each other, sure.
We'll bump into each other.
Literally she was in Florence
the weekend of my wedding.
Yeah, she knew the date.
- She was like, "Oh, that's so weird."
- She's a wedding crasher. I like it.
- I'm not gonna say that, but no, but no
- I wanna say that! That
makes her even more lovable.
It's awesome.
- She came, she was a champ,
she actually came as like, a plus one
- Yeah.
- to this like kickoff
drinks thing that we did
like two days before the
wedding with a buddy of mine.
And I was like, you gotta
come to the wedding,
you're in town, how crazy
is this? You gotta come.
- Yeah.
- Like, how random is it that
you're in the same place?
Come. She's like, "I can't
do it. I won't do it."
And I'm like, "I can't find a dress."
You're in Italy, you can find a dress.
- Yes, yeah.
- It's dresses everywhere in
Italy. You can find a dress.
So finally she gets to the wedding,
and literally after the
ceremony my mom walks over to me
and pulls me to the side
and my mom is like, "Did you
know Anna Kendrick was here?"
(Kelly laughing)
- And I was like, "Yeah!"
- Well it is my wedding.
- And she's like, I
took a picture with her
and I was like, mom, I just got married.
Like, I just got married.
- So let's just, perspective.
- Let's just
- Bring it in.
- You're still at the
wedding, just so you know.
- But it was a good time.
- We're supposed to be up
here in importance right now.
- Yeah.
- She's like, I'm over you.
But where are you from originally?
Because one of your parents
was in the Air Force, right?
- Yeah, so I was born in
Sumter, South Carolina.
- Okay.
- I went to 12 schools in 13
years, bounced all around.
- Wow!
- I ended up going to high
school in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
- Wow.
- Yeah. Middle school and high school.
- That's real different.
- Shout out to Tulsa. I was
just in Tulsa this weekend.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, but I bounced around.
My dad was in the Air Force,
my grandfathers were in the Air Force.
So it's a family thing.
We moved around a lot. A lot.
- So, do you think that that helped you?
Like we moved around a bit when I was,
do you think it, I think I'm
adaptive because of that.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Like, I think that
that probably helped you.
Or do you think that's one reason
why you became creative, as well?
- I definitely think like there was,
if I didn't like something going down
at like the previous school,
- Mhm.
- I would create a whole new character
and persona for my new school.
- An actor at a very young age.
(audience laughing)
- You know what I'm saying?
- My middle name is Ramone.
Yeah.
- And literally, I showed up to one school
and for two weeks, for
two weeks, I was like
(introduces self with
funny accent) Ramone.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I knew you were gonna do it-
- Ramone.
- (mimicking him back) Ramone.
- And I got destroyed because
there were Spanish
speaking kids at my school
and they would start speaking Spanish
and I'd be like, "I have
to go to the bathroom."
- And I would just turn around,
- (speaking Spanish) El baño!
and run away, yeah.
- So literally at the
next school I was like
that's not gonna work.
So we gotta figure out something else
- Oh my God, I love that you were
like "Ramone" and you were
like, I'm gonna be sexy here.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna be this
- My voice would get deeper.
- Yeah.
- Like my eight year old voice was like
(mimics squeaky voice) Ramone.
(both laughing)
- Oh God, turning all the
ladies on with your one word.
So today is the first day
of Black History Month.
You are part of a show made by
and starring black creators on "Insecure."
- Yeah.
- So I don't know, how do you think
that that show furthered the narrative
for black people in entertainment overall?
- Yeah. I mean, representation right?
- Great cast, yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Representation, so important.
- Representation is so important.
You know, it's amazing
how many people still walk
up to me and are like,
"I never saw myself until that show."
Like, I never saw myself
on TV until that show,
or a story, or I went through that
with my boyfriend, or my best friend
or whatever it is.
- So it's like sad but inspiring
- Sad, but it's, sad but inspiring.
- Yeah.
- But I think it is, I think to know
that you're not alone,
I think it's something
- Yeah.
- Because obviously those stories
weren't just created out of nothing.
They were created out of
real people's experiences.
And so I think like that's a huge thing.
And I think also like when
you look at the legacy
of those shows, you know,
if you look at that picture,
the folks in that picture,
especially behind the camera
like everyone has gone on
to either write another show
write a movie, direct
a movie or a TV show.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- I mean, literally Natasha has a show.
- Yeah.
- Prentiss has a couple of shows.
Wade has a movie.
I mean, everyone in this group literally
has gone on to do
absolutely amazing things.
And they're creating opportunity
for other people to create legacy
and bring other people into the room
who often don't get the opportunity.
- Opportunity is so important.
- Yeah.
- I heard that you,
speaking of people just coming up to you,
I heard that one time you
were in an airport, was it?
(Jay laughing)
And a lady came up and slapped you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And she
- She went back to like eighth grade
and she was like, Ramone,
I got something for you.
(Jay imitates hitting noise)
- (laughing) Your name was not Ramone.
Lies.
- Yeah, lies.
- Lies.
- Yeah.
So I was at the airport
and I was going to get,
I was going to like get
some Advil or something
from like one of those little turnstiles
in like the magazine store.
And there's a woman standing
on the other side of it
and before I turn it
I'm like, "Hey, excuse-"
and it's gonna bump into her if I turn it.
So I'm like, "Hey, excuse
me, I just wanna turn this."
She turns around and looks at me
and her eyes literally were like this big.
And she reached back and it was so far
that I could have probably dodged it.
- It was like slow mo.
- It was like slow-
but it was also, I couldn't
believe what was happening.
And literally she, I mean you could hear
her hand cut through the
wind just (mimics wind)
and like slap across my face,
- Which is not okay.
- At all.
- No.
- But she immediately went
to like, McCulley Caulkin
and she was like, "Oh, my God,"
like she started screaming
and she's like, "I'm so sorry,
I didn't mean to do that,
you remind me of my ex-boyfriend,
like Lawrence is just like him,
and like seeing you was seeing
him, and like, I'm just-"
and literally it was this crazy moment
- Like Ma'am.
That's not okay.
- What am I supposed to say?
(audience laughing)
- That-
- Lawrence is triggering, you know? Like,
what am I supposed to say?
- But that's a character.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- But for some people,
I listen, I always say
- Like if somebody walked up and was like,
I hated "Since You've Been Gone," like,
(Jay laughing)
- Like, that's your
problem, ma'am. Like what?
- That's true.
- Yeah, that's weird.
That's definitely
not acceptable.
- But I wasn't gonna call
airport police on her.
- That's 'cause you're nice.
(audience and Jay laughing)
So tell us about the new movie,
"Somebody That I Used To
Know." Who do you play in it?
- I play a character named Sean,
who's like a hometown boy, never left
and has always had this like,
perfect vision for his life
and what he thought it was supposed to be.
And that all kind of gets
upended in this weekend
when he's supposed to get married.
And Alison Brie and Dave
Franco, the amazing power couple
that they are, they wrote this
movie during the pandemic.
They were sitting around
watching a bunch of rom-coms
and they were like, "We love this genre."
- Yeah.
- We miss this genre, like
- I love this genre.
- We want to do something here.
- Yeah.
- And they wrote this movie together,
Dave directed it,
Kiersey Clemons plays
the woman that I am marrying in this movie
who's also just so brilliant.
And anyway, Allison's character
comes home one weekend
we bump into each other and she's like
"I think I still like this dude,"
not realizing that I'm
getting married that weekend.
- (mimics sad trombone) Bah-bah-bah...
- Womp-womp-womp.
- Yeah.
- And so basically it's her, you know,
trying to see if she can get in the way of
- Ugh, happiness.
- My upcoming, yeah, my upcoming wedding.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- So they're married and like
he's the director, right?
- Yeah.
- So like you and Allison have like
intimate scenes, like,
(Jay laughing)
what's that like with the husband?
- It's, you know, it's awkward, you know.
(audience laughing)
- That's awkward as hell.
- Yeah it's-
- I mean I know you're
all actors obviously,
Like you're paid professionally,
you're good at what you do.
You've been "Ramone", you've
been all these people,
- I mean...
(Jay laughing)
- But I just mean like,
that would be really awkward
to be like, "Is this okay?"
Like, am I fine or-
- I'll never forget there
was this scene that we did,
it's actually this really beautiful scene,
they spend this whole night together,
I'm not gonna give away the whole thing,
Amazon's probably here
watching me right now.
(Kelly laughing)
- But they spend this whole night together
and then there's this scene in the morning
where they're like sitting at this spot
that they used to hang out at
and watching the sun come up.
And I'll never forget,
we were probably about
this far away from each
other and Dave's like,
"Jay, you could scoot a little closer."
And I was like, "Huh?"
- Huh?
- Say what? You want me to do what?
You want me to scoot closer? Okay.
- Fine.
(Jay and Kelly laughing)
- It's like, "Jay that was like,
you barely even moved, man.
Like, can you scoot closer?"
And I'm like, "Are you sure?"
There's just, it feels like
we're really close, Dave.
- It was like, room for the Lord.
- To your wife.
It feels like I'm really
close to your wife, man.
But it was great.
He was amazing about it.
They're both amazing.
They're so cool and easy.
- I mean, obviously you're
all actors. I get it.
- Yeah.
- I just mean, it's still,
for a person that's not an actor,
I'm like, "Why are you so close?"
Like why, what are you doing?
- I definitely was still like
looking over my shoulder the whole time.
Like, are you good?
You're good with this?
You're not gonna hit me
across the back of the head
when I turn around, to do the thing.
- I don't mean anything,
I'm a really good actor.
(Jay and Kelly laughing)
Well, streaking plays a cameo
in the movie, which I love.
Who doesn't? Have you
ever really done that?
- I have.
Yes.
- I have, as well.
- Streaked. I've streaked before.
I've streaked across in
the middle of my campus
when I was in college.
- Oh, my God! You're
totally like old school.
- Yeah.
- We're going streaking at the quad.
Like, it's like (laughing)
that's amazing.
- That's, it was in our quad actually.
It literally was in our quad. It was-
- You were the inspiration.
- It was a basketball dare.
- Okay.
- I played college
basketball and it was a dare.
It wasn't a dare. It
was like, it was a dare
more or less, let's just call it
from like a bunch of my teammates.
We were all together one night.
- Yeah.
- And myself and one of my other teammates
streaked across campus at like
one o'clock in the morning.
- Nudity is funny.
- It's funny.
- It's funny. It's great.
- It's funny when you're running, too.
- Just, you know, it's
just all out, you know,
everything's just out there, you know.
- Streaking is different
when you get older.
(Kelly and Jay laughing)
- It gets a little more sloppy.
It's a little different.
- I don't know, like, this
doesn't feel as good anymore.
- That's like, I don't care.
But y'all probably do.